-Our first guest is a
Tony-winning and Oscar-nominated
actor who stars in the new
movie, "The Eyes of Tammy Faye."
You guys have to see this.
It's amazing.
It is in theaters this Friday.
Please welcome Andrew Garfield,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's my man.
That's what I'm
talking about, buddy.
Yes. Oh, my gosh.
You are great
in this movie, buddy.
I want to talk about it.
It's good to see you.
How you doing?
-It's good to see you, too.
Very, very happy to be here
but truly wish I could
be there in person.
I'm in Calgary, a little bit
stuck here doing a show,
but lovely to be able
to talk to you.
How are you?
-I'm good.
I appreciate you coming
on the show, as we all do.
Yeah, we --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait till you see.
We have an audience.
We're coming back, buddy.
Anyways, a seat's always open --
-I feel it.
-Seat's always open for you.
We have -- It's Broadway week
here on our show, and --
-Whoo!
-Yeah.
We are honoring, yeah, a bunch
of amazing Broadway shows.
And you are a Tony winner.
I -- Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know the stage pretty well.
You know anything can happen
in live theater.
Did anything ever happen to you
during a live performance
where there was a mess-up
where you're like,
"Oh, this is going to be tough
to work through"?
-[ Laughs ] My -- My butt
was facing the audience
for a prolonged period of time
during "Angels in America."
It was -- I'm in the middle
of a fight with an angel.
And if you know the show,
that makes sense.
If you don't,
it's going to sound odd.
But I'm in, like, hospital
kind of garments,
and I'm about to be hoisted up
on a harness
with this angel
into the rafters.
And me and the angel
are wrestling.
I've got my arms
around her waist,
and we're kind of,
like, pretending
that we're going to wrestle.
And then we give the guys
in the wings the go-ahead,
like, "We're ready to go."
I've got my hands in the loops.
We're ready to go up.
And we give them the sign,
and, like,
it feels like 89 minutes passes,
and we're just, like,
pretending to wrestle
and like, "Why aren't we
going into the air?"
-And your -- your butt
is facing the audience?
-My butt is fully just --
Just giving full face
to the crowd.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, you're pretending
to struggle, fight,
but nothing's happening?
-Yeah.
And nothing's happening.
And my -- my pancake ass
is just, like,
on full display.
And -- And the guys
in the wings --
The guys in the wings are like,
"It's just not --
I don't know how.
It's just not working."
And we're like this.
So I'm like what do we do?
Do we just keep wrestling
with my butt facing everybody?
And I-I guess
that's what we did.
Until -- And this is where
it gets really awkward.
The stage -- The stage manager
walks out
under this really dramatic music
that's happening,
with a microphone.
And he's like, "Um --"
It was a British guy.
He's like, "Um, so sorry,
ladies and gentlemen,
but we're having some
technical difficulties.
We're going to have to
take a pause."
And meanwhile, like,
me and this actress, Mandy,
were just, like,
still wrestling.
[ Laughter ]
And he stood right next to us.
And then the curtain comes down
in front of my ass.
[ Laughter ]
And then, like, literally,
like, I'm like --
I'm like, "What do we do? How do
we -- How do we keep the --
Like, when we figure out
this technical thing,
how do we start the show again?"
And I was like,
"I've got an idea!
Let me put my ass
to the audience,
and as soon
as the curtain comes up,
just send me up
on the God damn rig."
Like, we picked up
exactly where we left off.
-That's the best, dude.
What else can you do?
-What else can you do?
I have -- I have
a couple questions.
First of all,
you look like a stud
on the cover of "Variety" here.
Hey, not too shabby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to -- There's a photo
going around on the Internet
of you and Tobey Maguire
on the set of "Spider-Man,"
yeah, the new "Spider-Man,"
movie, and --
And I was like, "Wow, that --"
-I'm not sure about that.
-We are.
We're pretty sure.
We're pretty sure about it,
so we know what's up.
Do you know what's up?
Are --
[ Laughter ]
What I'm telling you is,
you're going to be --
You're in the new
"Spider-Man: No Way Home."
Congratulations.
-Wait, what?
-Yes! Congratulations.
You're going to be in it. Yeah.
That's exciting, right?
-I had no idea.
Like, if --
-Have you seen the photo?
-What -- What --
What are you talking about?
-Yeah, you wouldn't
see the photo,
because you're in the photo.
-No, yeah, it's not possible
to see a photo that you're in.
-That's correct.
-No, I-I --
No, I --
-I'm the worse detective ever.
"How could you be in this
if you're there?"
[ Laughter, applause ]
"Ah, it's a photo."
[ Both laugh ]
I am the worst detective.
-Well, if you show me the photo,
I can tell you whether it's me
or whether it's a real thing.
But until I see the photo --
-It's been erased
off the Internet.
-Oh, how convenient,
Detective Fallon.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm just saying. Yeah --
Yeah, it's been erased.
But it was around,
and we all saw it, and --
-I heard about it.
And I did see it.
And it's a photoshop.
-Oh.
-No!
-We say no.
-I'm trying to manage
expectations.
You say no. Oh, you say no.
[ Laughter ]
-We're saying no.
We're saying they should
reshoot the film.
They should reshoot --
They got to reshoot the film.
-Listen, if they want
to give me a call
at this late, late stage
of the game,
you know, I'm sitting here
in my track suit.
-Have you seen the trailer?
I know you're a Spider-Man fan,
because we've talked about it
when you were Spider-Man,
but have you seen the trailer
to this new one?
-I have, and I'm excited.
And I think that Tom Holland
is just the perfect Peter Parker
and Spider-Man,
so I'm just super stoked.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, he's good. He's good.
-And -- And I -- And I get
to just, like, be a fan again,
which is my preferred position,
to be able to sit in the
audience and just kind of go,
"Yeah, you screwed up, mate.
You didn't do it as well
as you could have done, eh?"
Like, I get to be that guy,
that's just like, "Yeah,
I don't really love the suit,
and I don't really love the --"
I get to be that person,
which is much more fun.
-I want to talk to you, because,
man, you totally transform
in this movie
"The Eyes of Tammy Faye,"
and I want to get into it.
More with Andrew Garfield
when we come back, everybody.